alright guys first off sorry about the
delay there I'm just gonna start slowly
here today because we had another link
that we normally set up through the
TriCaster through our studio cameras and
the whole freaking thing and then the
TriCaster some of you know about the
TriCaster the TriCaster is like one of
the few ways that you can sort of build
out a studio and control all the cameras
and all that it is a notoriously
herky-jerky thing that often has crazy
bugs and a mirror here our director who
was an absolutely pro at all this and
has been doing this for years she did
every possible thing imaginable so that
we could be doing this normally as we
normally do it through our regular
cameras and all that good stuff and I'm
miked up and it's lit well and
everything but for some reason the
TriCaster just didn't want to play along
I don't know what the hell's going on so
we're doing this old-school people I've
got my laptop right in front of me and
we're just we're gonna do it this way
there's a whole bunch of stuff that I
want to catch up with you guys on you
know I've been on this tour with JP
Jordan Peterson and because of that for
the last whatever it is almost six eight
weeks I haven't been doing direct
messages at the front end of the shows
and that's usually where I'm able to
tell you guys what I've been thinking
about what's on my mind what I think is
relevant and important and all that
stuff but we just haven't been able to
do that because although we've taped
some shows in advance usually when I'm
doing something that's on my mind at the
moment there's a bit of a topical nature
to it so I don't want to tape a DM even
a week in advance and then lay it out
when it feels stale or also I haven't
had a moment in the last couple weeks to
just go directly to you guys what I have
had is a couple chances to do that with
with those of you who are on patreon
because I do the one-on-ones and the
group hangouts and all that kind of
stuff so I've been able to share some
thoughts about this tour and just all
the kinds of stuff that's going on and
then I want to share some some personal
stuff some business stuff we're gonna do
an AMA you guys can ask me anything you
can do that on super chat right here so
for those of you that don't have super
chat works if you throw in a couple
bucks in the youtube comment section it
pumps your comments up I'm pretty sure
that the more you put the longer it
stays up there then my guys can see it
and they send it to me we've got to
trust the iPad here with patreon
questions rolling in
and with with super chat comments
rolling in and all that good stuff we
are streaming right now we're only
streaming on YouTube sometimes we stream
this on on Facebook as well but because
of this whacked-out TriCaster situation
we're just doing it this way yes I am
wearing the classical liberal t-shirt
many of you guys saw no this is a good
place to start actually so last week we
posted I believe it was was it last
Tuesday if I'm not mistaken a week ago
today we posted our first-ever Rubin
report animated video it was a two
minute 37 second video a short that I
wrote and did the voiceover for and we
got a great animator who came in and we
did what is classical liberalism it got
something like last I saw I think it at
around 650,000 views on Twitter I think
it's got about a hundred thousand on
YouTube which is kind of an interesting
little thing about the algorithms and
whatever else is going on here with the
feeds or however you guys ingest this
content there's something interesting
happening so think about this I have
about last night so I think it's around
400 some odd thousand Twitter followers
the video on Twitter got about 700,000
views we have almost 800,000 subscribers
on YouTube so basically double the
subscribers that I have on Twitter the
video got at last I saw it was a little
bit under a hundred thousand views now
you guys keep bumping into you guys on
the street or when I go to the Petersons
events from you guys email me and keep
telling me I'm subscribed but I don't
see the videos I know what's going on
with the feed I get the usual nonsense
from YouTube hoon I don't know what the
answer to any of it is anymore I'm just
gonna keep putting out stuff and
hopefully for those of you that don't
see the videos in your feeds or whatever
they are hopefully you do a little extra
legwork to find this stuff but we're
doing we're doing the best we can we're
also working on a couple things that I
can't quite get into yet on that front
how is that for a tease we're just
working on some stuff on that front
anyway we put this video out and what I
wanted to do with this was because
obviously in the last two years and I
think it has a little something to do
with what we've been doing around here
the ideas of classical liberalism have
been catching on and something sort of
beautiful happened today that I'm sure
many of you saw Barack Obama former
President Barack Obama was given a
speech
and he talked about how you cannot
automatically dismiss people's opinions
just because they're male or just
because they're white I mean I suspect
that the conversations that we've all
been having here between Peterson and
Rogan and the line Stein's and Sam
Harris and Shapiro and everybody else
but these conversations we know I mean I
can't get into every little detail of
how we know everything you know but we
know that these conversations have moved
up the ladder and then a lot of people
all over the world important powerful
people are taking note of this and
taking note of the massive amounts of
numbers of people that are listening to
these podcasts and being influenced by
the stuff and the fact that Peterson has
sold about two million books it may be
more than two million already about a
month ago is one and a half million I
mean this thing is it's it's actually
incredible when I was in DC a couple
weeks ago for the Petersen event and
then I did a I did a sold-out show I'm
back doing stand-up and I did a sold-out
show at the DC Improv it was awesome
thank you for all of you guys that came
there and we did a meet-and-greet after
which was totally fun it was great I
brought up christina hoff sommers for
the second half the show's great but
anyway I was in DC and I went to this
little party and I got on I can't say
who was there because I don't know if he
wants to be known as somebody but there
was a senator there who was a very
influential senator one of the most
influential senators and all of the
Senate and he was there and I walked in
and he's like hey Dave Rubin I know
you're on tour Peterson I'm reading this
book right now so cool things are
happening this stuff is starting to
percolate and I don't think it's a
coincidence that Barack Obama came out
and did a real that was a real swipe of
identity politics and you know it's
interesting because there's so many
things happening here at once and we're
watching the massive realignment of
politics and media it's all happening
together this is the fertile ground
we've been talking about for the last
couple of years here we're watching it
sort of all shake out right now and we
don't know what'll be on the other side
but it's exciting I think if you're
aware and you're you got a couple
neurons still firing and you're paying
attention to what's going on
so when Barack Obama does that that's a
signal I think to some of the same
lefties and by the way there are sane
lefties right I used to know a lot of
them
and we need I think a Seine left and a
Seine right and I would love to see for
all of my frustrations with the left
that you guys know I talk about all
times and I hate identity politics and I
hate what the Democratic Party has
become and the oppression Olympics and
all of this nonsense and I think they're
way too big government and all of that
for all of that if the same part of the
Left came back the part of the left that
for those of you that are libertarian or
conservative or whatever that you may
disagree with but I think you believe
our principles or should at least
believe their principles so if the part
of the left that say Brett Weinstein who
considered himself deeply progressive
for his whole life believed in or his
wife Heather I believed in if that same
part of the left were the part of the
left that I once was part of when I
considered myself a Democrat and when
Democrats were actually liberal not
leftist when they were open-minded not
so talat Arian if that came back that
would be good for everything so there's
something interesting going on right now
because I see right now I see three sort
of distinct pieces or we could say I see
three distinct units on the right so
right now you've got the Trump people
the magg of people okay big column right
there that's a that's an ideological
column then you have the never Trump
pers the sort of more old-school
conservatives BAM okay these are very
separate people but they're thought of
on the right or they're thought of as
Republican or conservative whatever you
want to call that then there's also what
I with the part that I like the most
which is I think there is a very strong
growing libertarian wing of the
conservative party when I go to these
Peterson events when I speak at colleges
when I do stand-up I talked about
libertarian ideas and that's when people
get most excited so there's three
distinct ideologies right now within the
right so to speak right so we've got the
trunkpeople the never Trump people
old-school conservatives and we've got
libertarians they're all fighting for
control of their thing of their party of
their ideology all that that's great
that's a beautiful thing you know it's
unfortunately when you just see them
fighting at each other to the point
where they hate each other and these
people are evil and those people that
gets nobody anywhere what a beautiful
thing you if you have an idea
logical war the right way like really
fighting out ideas that's a beautiful
thing and I think that's what we try to
do around here
right now on the left unfortunately we
don't see as much of that because there
has been a purging of the Liberals and
the progressives and the Democratic
socialists and that crew that wants
really big government and that does
judge on your skin color and your
immutable characteristics and thinks
that government can solve all the
problems they have basically purged out
all the same
San Jose saying all the the more
pleasant thoughtful liberals let's say
and I do see and that's why I said this
would be the year of unusual alliances I
see a lot of old-school liberals finding
a lot more in common in common with
old-school conservatives are certainly
the libertarian people and I guess some
of them are Magga people too but there
isn't an ideological fight there really
because it's basically just been a
slaughter where there's almost nobody
left so that's why today I thought was
so interesting because by Obama saying
in effect he said identity politics are
[ __ ] and you have to be able to
listen to people even scary
white men yeah you have to be able to
listen to them because they might have
good ideas that's pretty powerful and if
that signals some sort of comeback on
the left of that theory and and that
takes root a little bit I think that
would be great and you know Peterson in
a lot of the events that we talk about
because one of the things that happens
is we do a Q&A at the end of what
happens is we use an app called slide oh
so when we first started we were just
letting people come up to the mic to do
the Q&A but what happens is people are
so excited they end up telling their
life story and they very long-winded
things and sometimes they're very
nervous and they lose their train of
thought and a whole bunch of stuff and
we want to get to as many questions as
possible so what we do now is there's an
app called slide o SLI do and people
that are in the audience and they're
usually three to four or five thousand
people at the audience in these shows
and it's just been incredible I'll tell
you a little bit more about that later
people submit questions on the app and
then while Peterson is doing his thing
so basically the way the show works is I
go up there for about 10 or 15 minutes I
do warm up I welcome everybody we do
some silly stuff I talked about lobsters
and cleaning your room
I just get everybody going and
everybody's in a great mood and people
are screaming and it's and it's just
wonderful it's none of the things that
these awful articles and slime ball
you know hack pieces are saying about it
what about what's going on there so
anyway so I do my thing that I bring out
Peters and Jordan talks about everything
everything under the Sun for an hour
sometimes he talks about the 12 rules
sometimes he talked about the media
sometimes he talks about the
intellectual dark web some 90 talks
about what what whatever else is on is
mine every single one of these shows has
been different it's been it's been truly
incredible being on this tour I mean the
guy is a true tour de force and whether
you love them or hate them or you're
different or whatever it's like it's
just so cool being around it I've just
thoroughly enjoyed every every second of
the end I've enjoyed also just bouncing
around from city to city and figuring
out which cities I like orange and just
the differences of the people I gotta
say many of you guys were at the
Nashville show you were the happiest
freaking bunch of people I've ever seen
in my entire life I don't know what is
in the water in Nashville but that's the
one that really stuck out to me and we
were in the Ryman theater which is from
the Grand Ole Opry and just the history
there but we've been an amazing theaters
and it's so cool cuz we go to these
really old school theaters that are kind
of like Phantom of the Opera that we've
been to some some newer more modern
theaters and just and the people are
great name
in any event people submit questions
during the show and then while Jordans
doing his thing I basically look through
them and Jordan made it very clear to me
from the beginning he said nothing is
off-limits I want you to challenge me
etcetera etcetera so I go through I find
some silly ones I find some funny ones I
find some some some painful ones I find
some hard ones some political ones some
not political ones some personal ones
psychological questions I mean all sorts
of stuff now and we do that at the end
for about 30 to 45 minutes and it's just
it's just been absolutely great and you
know it's so funny because being on this
tour with the guy it's like as were on
the tour hit pieces come out so like
that ridiculous enforced monogamy
article came out in the New York Times
and I had met the author of it two or
three days before she was sitting in the
green room with us at our first show in
Toronto and it's like she seemed like a
great gal I talked about this a little
bit when I
had Jordan in here with Eric Weinstein a
couple weeks ago and it's like and then
just writes this piece that as if Jordan
is trying to force anyone to be married
or force women into monogamy or anything
enforcement either he meant marriage
that's all he meant and it's like you
watch these people in these slime bags
and often I've invited people to come to
the show after they've written bad
pieces there's been a writer a guy from
the Blais who spent a couple days with
us who's writing a piece right now and
wrote a profile piece on me a couple
months ago that I think is gonna be an
excellent piece coming out about the
tour because I took the time to learn to
trust the guy as much as I can trust a
reporter and and we spent some time with
him and all that but unfortunately you
know what's happened these days because
of the clickbait machine that you guys
know about that these guys real all of
these reporters but they're activists
they're not journalists and what they do
is they go holy cow
Peterson's got the number one book he's
selling out these theaters now he's
doing these things with sam harris where
they're getting you know 8,000 9,000
people overseas and it's like well
instead of learning what's actually
going there so instead of actually
showing up to the show and reporting on
the truth that has nothing to do with
racism or misogyny he's actually giving
you the tools by empowering your own
life by cleaning your own room he's
giving you the tools to not be racist to
not be beginning to not to hate cultural
Marxism and the progressive politics of
the oppression Olympics of all of that
stuff he's telling you hate that but
also well not not hate it that's not
even the right word know what it is and
know why it's wrong and then he's also
saying the identity politics of the
right are just as bad he focuses more on
the left as I focus more left
because that seems to be the thing
that's the cultural norm that is jammed
down our throat every day but these
reporters they don't even show up to
these things because they just want to
write something so that they can get
more clicks they're just in the click
business and and I don't think any of us
you know this whole crew of people IDW
whatever you want to call it I don't
think we're in the click business
there'd be a lot of ways for us to get
more clicks I mean you can look at the
way we tag and title all of our videos
we know if we use certain buzzwords
we'll capitalize certain things differ
Lior gotcha destroys it's like we know
we could get more clicks but it's really
not about that we're doing good and I
try to treat the channel the same way I
treat the conversations that I'm having
with you guys and I think one of the
things that's really happening here is
that out of this whole crew of people
it's like we genuinely respect you I
want to hear from you the fact that we
go out there now and it's so awesome
there's been a couple nights where
Jordan and I have just walked out into
the audience there there was sometimes
there's a line around the block I mean
literally around four square blocks in
Seattle
wrapped around it was awesome and we
just go out there and say hi to people
when I've been wandering around the the
cities during the day people come up to
me and they want to take me out to
dinner and drink and I join some people
some time one night where the hell was
it Portland I was I was pretty beat
after the show because it had been a
long run and I went back to my hotel and
I was just gonna have half a glass of
wine at the bar and it turned out that
like 40 people from the show were there
we hung out did our thing there so it's
just it's just been wonderful and
inspiring and for me look you guys know
I rail against the mainstream media all
the time and it's like wow this thing
being part of this thing has just it's
been the proof in the pudding you know
what I mean like they say the proof is
in the pudding well all the things that
I'm always talking about how these
people are lying and not telling you
what's really going on and really going
to these places and telling you the
truth about what's happening and it's
like I'm there I know what's happening
and then I read these articles and oh my
god you guys are all crap you're all
crap ola on a stick
so anyway well I'm all over the place
here so well back up for a moment so we
threw up that that classical liberal
video two and a half minutes I think
we're it got a great reaction tons of
views people people were really happy
with it and I think we're gonna try to
do one of those a month which by the way
those of you who support us on patreon
or PayPal or super chat or whatever
you're doing those will what you're
supporting us with will help us fund
those because they're not cheap to make
but I'm super psyched to do more of
those I think is a good way to get quick
bytes of information to people and it's
like you can't give everybody everything
in two-and-a-half minutes but what you
can do is open the door so my hope with
that video was somebody would watch
that maybe was kind of like seeing
what's happening on the left and not
really sure and doesn't have to put it
into language to to really get out what
they're thinking my hope is that you'll
watch that and go alright there's
something there and then guess what you
could do a little research on on your
own you could go by on liberty by John
Stuart Mill you can get it for like five
bucks on Amazon and and start learning
about some of these ideas and you know
so we're gonna keep doing more of them I
think it's really cool and that's why
I'm wearing the classical liberal shirt
today and I sense that these ideas are
coming back and for you know all the
people right now there's so many people
you go on Twitter you go on all these
things and everybody the sky is falling
everything's horrible World War three is
gonna begin nice all these people do
civil war has forgotten about guys
things have been bad in the past things
may feel bad now there's so many good
signs also and that's one of the things
Jordans been talking about too and then
a book that I have right over there
Steven Pinker enlightenment now there
are so many trends about how violence is
actually on the decrease now how far
station I think in North America is
actually expanding how clean water is
now accessible to more people than ever
before I mean all sorts of things but we
always focus on the negative and that
doesn't mean there aren't things to fix
and boy do we have a political
whacked-out political situation right
now and people that are just really
angry at each other often for no good
reason and we have also a set now of
media people who just want to keep you
enraged all the time and I just don't
want to have anything to do with that
stuff so I'm just gonna keep doing what
I think is right so anyway so here's
what I want to do there are a few other
things that I want to tell you about but
I do want to do a Q&A also so I know
they were resilient questions and
patreon already will jump in on super
chat so if you're watching this live on
YouTube right now you throw in a couple
bucks your question gets bumped up and
more I think you put in the higher the
longer it'll stay there so that we can
see it that an iPad so they're sending
me stuff okay oh Bunty King sends us
says I'm a sexy boy spell be a lie
I guess Thank You Bundy King do you
super track do you feel like the
ringmaster of the IDW so I kind of feel
a little bit like the the connective
tissue of some of this stuff you know
you mean like I'm not an academic
like Jordan is an academic right Brett
is an academic eric is an academic etc
Heather is an academic etcetera etc I
don't have a PhD in neuroscience like
Sam Harris but what I think I am is
someone who can communicate these ideas
really well who is curious about this
who really probably is a little more
like you in a lot of ways than I am like
these guys and I happen to be part of
these conversations it's the stuff that
I think about that I'm deeply passionate
about that I care about that I love
being part of this thing some of you
guys may have seen the picture from
about a week and a half ago where me and
Brogan and Eric Weinstein and Peterson
and Sam Harris and Shapiro went out to
dinner and it's like they someone took a
picture and they posted and it was like
wow the amount of retweets the thousands
tens of thousands of retweets and
comments and then of course all the
haters saying all sorts of ridiculous
things but it's like you guys are
invested in this thing I know it I can
feel it when you come up to me in the
airport like something is shifting and I
think at some level and I've been saying
this at some of the shows I think it's
some level were winning right now which
is why some of this stuff I do think is
even bubbling up to where perhaps there
was some connection where Barack Obama
starts talking entire identity politics
pretty great and I think it's directly
connected to us but ideas kind of move
up and around and people start talking
about things oh did you read the
Peterson book today did you hear Shapiro
and Peterson weinstein talking on ruben
show like you guys know how this all
works right so I'm I'm super excited
about all that so I love being part of
this thing and I feel like what we're
doing actually matters and that does of
course bring out the haters right like
I've got more haters now than ever and
these trolls that endlessly all day long
like I like I've said this before I like
the good trolls like you're gonna mean
me do silly stuff there's a guy who
keeps taking Peterson to me and like
making it sound like we're saying things
that we're not but doing it in like a
funny way of course I love that stuff
you do cartoons about me that are silly
and all that it's all good it's just
these endless angry people that and
people you know people want to attack
you so that you'll respond to them so
that they can get more views and that's
often you views or clicks and that's
often what's happening with Jordan to me
it's like just I don't want anything to
do with you people
I'm doing the best I can I'm open to
engage in anyone that will engage
honestly indeed and just be a decent
human being and I'm here for you and
I'll continue that conversation so so
anyway that your question um I don't
know that I'm the ringleader of it but I
guess that I guess at some level but I
love being part of it and I think it's
so cool what we're doing and I think
it's so cool that you guys are so ahead
of the curve on it it's just awesome all
right let me jump over to patreon let's
see how much longer till we can get you
on it you Jujitsu map it'll enhance your
life sir I know what between all these
guys that I'm around now Rogan and Sam
and the rest that are all in today I'm
I'm a so I should start doing something
you know because I've been on the road
I've actually been able to get to the
gym a lot I think I'm at my lowest
weight and probably like 20 years right
now and I'm feeling pretty fit I'm
eating right I'm still doing this
basically paleo situation and it's not
you know people say well it's on the
road it's like tough to eat right and
sleep right and all that I've actually
found it to be the the opposite because
when I'm here it's like there is so much
going on with the show and the company
that we've built behind it and
everything I was like there is not a
second there is not a second and when I
take a second I'm losing something else
right but when I'm on the road it's like
yeah my phones blowing up and I know
there's always something to attend to or
whatever but like I have more time to
actually get to the gym or find
something to eat that's the right thing
to eat instead of just scarfing
something down for the wrong reason so
I'd love to get on it jiu-jitsu mat I
did um acupuncture last night for the
first time in my life and I so I tweeted
out something about acupuncture I
thought this is pretty calm right
nobody's gonna get upset by this
then a zillion people always say it's
fake so I answer mama I don't know I
went to acupuncture and I can tell you
this guy you know pins me blah blah blah
blah about a half hour I lay there and I
was kind of tripping it felt like I was
like low-grade tripping like I had my
eyes closed listening to some music and
I was kind of seeing stars and flowers
opening up and all kinds of weird things
and like a sort of tunnel situation and
I did feel great and I did it at about 6
o'clock 6 p.m. last night came home had
a light and her went to bed pretty early
maybe 11 o'clock or so and I slept home
9 a.m. I haven't slept I usually get up
now
like six thirty or something naturally
that's up till nine and so I don't know
what the science behind all of it is and
I'd love to discuss that with somebody
but I did I did kind of kind of enjoy
all right let's see um dennis prager in
a recent ben shapiro interview said that
belief in an afterlife is what keeps him
sane do you think everyone pragmatically
lives as if there were an afterlife even
if they say they may not actually
believe in it well I definitely wouldn't
say everyone I mean I there are there
are absolutely people who say they don't
believe in an afterlife who don't
believe in an afterlife so I definitely
wouldn't say everyone I think that the
idea of an afterlife that if that if
you're good here that somehow it's gonna
get you to some shangri-la magical
cloudy place after probably does keep
people in check a little bit right the
idea that if God is watching you that it
that then because you might get
somewhere after you go but you might be
on your best behavior I think some
people believe in that I I don't
particularly believe in that you know
when I had John Kasich in here the
governor of Ohio who ran for president
we talked to just a bit about that at
the beginning where he because he was
talking about how his faith and his
faith is one of the things that keeps
him on the path and he said something
that I thought was interesting because
he said that you know that there's a
humanist philosophy of it that you can
just kind of do it yourself and he said
that wasn't enough for him I thought
that was actually a pretty honest
statement for a politician he wasn't
saying I don't think that those are good
people either don't believe in God or or
don't pray or don't go to church or
whatever it is you're saying that for
him personally his faith I assume he
meant his faith in God or or in Christ
or whatever it is that that gives him
personally the strength to do what he
sees as right personally I I do the best
I can to be the best person I can be I
fail at it often and I think you
probably do too and whether you get the
strength to do that because you believe
there's an afterlife or because you
believe someone's watching you or
because you just it's good in you your
Constitution is strong enough to to
always do there
right thing or whatever I don't know
that it matters that much it's one of
the cool things actually right now I
mean these conversations that that
Jordan and Sam are having where they're
really they're talking about the essence
of truth and religion God and free will
and all of this it's interesting to me
because I think there's a secondary
conversation to happen and maybe after
they've done a couple of these they've
done four of them now maybe I can host a
conversation where I think we get to the
next step of this which is all right I
know both these guys I think they're
both very good human beings I like them
both a lot they have a very divergent
view when it comes to these big
existential questions on a micro level I
don't think it matters at all that one
of them that Jordan say is a believer or
believes in the importance of the
archetypes of religious stories and
believes that they have some other
meaning some deep profound truth comes
out of those things and Sam does not
believe in that on a personal level I
don't think and a micro level I don't
think it matters because we can all
exist together and enjoy each other's
company and collaborate on things and
whatever on a good question and Prager
brought this up when I did the god of
morality debate with him and Michael
Shermer on a macro level do you need
some unifier in his in his case he would
argue being religion or something from
the judeo-christian tradition do you
need that to keep a society moving do
you need this belief in an unmoved mover
sort of thing I don't know what the
answer to that is I know buddy really
knows what the answer to that is but I
think it's an interesting question and I
think what's cool is the fact that so
many people are showing up to talk about
this so I think the the secondary
question of all of this is does it
matter once once we make the arguments
that we make and all of the people who
are really thinking about this stuff and
a lot of people don't have time to think
about this stuff a lot of people it's
not within their nature to think about
this stuff but all of the people who
really care about what what truth is and
why do you either need or not need the
stories and the archetypes and religion
all those things once you get past that
does it matter if you can coexist with
the guy who lives next door who happens
to be an atheist and you happen to be a
religious person I think
that's an interesting place to start
taking this next but you know we're kind
of that's what's cool about this the
more conversations that we have and the
more open inquiry we allow we allow for
more room for a lot of other
conversations so I think it's actually
very cool okay here we go
hi Dave I belonged to a local Jordan
Peterson meet up and we discuss thinkers
like you and Weinstein is live do you
have some good tips for quality
conversations with the other side the
quote other side is what yeah there um
look the best you can do is welcome
these people in hear them out and then
try there they're gonna be on the
defensive often because they're not
armed with facts and they do feel very
passionately about these things and the
more that you give them facts if it
affects what they're feeling they're
they're gonna keep backing up keep
backing up just trying to show people
you're decent try to show them that
you're extending the olive branch etc
said are you reaching out to them all of
that if you try to do that I think
eventually we can get some of these
people you know this mob that we're
always talking about the mob eventually
will come from them if you're one of the
people in the mob right now and you're
angry at me and you probably right and
mean things in the comments section you
right now a person I'm talking to you
who hates me who's watching I always
love that there's so many people who
hate that spend their time watching this
like if you're doing that know that
generally the people that I'm sort of
around and the conversations on that we
we don't hate you I don't know you I I
would I think that we're discussing the
ideas that I think are a good set of
ideas to help society move forward I
think there's great discussions about
should there be less government or more
government the questions that I just
talked about about God and existence and
truth we have to show these people I
think that we're not the bad guys we're
not the things that people are saying
about us and that the reasons people are
so angry often with us and why so many
people seem to hate us and these
articles come out is because they know
there's an essence of truth there's a
kernel of truth in what we're doing and
they don't know how to deal with that so
I suspect that's what you'd be dealing
with a lot and I think if you keep
welcoming people in and keep going keep
look around this room you
racists here look around this room you
think there's any misogynist he or
homophobes here it's like come on man
there aren't so I know it ain't easy got
to see the show in Austin and it was
great love what you're doing mr. Ruben
and I thank you thank you sir
hi Dave what's been the most surprising
thing you've learned while spending so
much time with Peterson loved the show
um well I don't know that this is
particularly surprising but I can tell
you this is absolutely true he is the
same exact person when those cameras are
off then when he is when the cameras are
on so usually what goes on during the
shows is you know where we get to these
towns I usually get there pretty early
in the morning some sometimes we travel
together sometimes we haven't check into
my hotel do my thing kind of wander
around a little bit maybe hit the gym
and then usually get to the to the show
about to the theater about an hour
before Jordan gets there about the same
time we have two separate dressing rooms
he gets the you know the star's dressing
room I get the smaller one but it's all
good
I usually go into his dressing room for
a little bit we chat for about 20
minutes and it's like we talk about the
same stuff like it's not like we're
suddenly talking about some other weird
thing or paving differently or anything
it's like immediately it's like and then
you know we have to talk about cultural
marxism and his hands are moving every
which way and the whole thing and it's
like it's real he's living it and it's
real and I think you guys are living it
too and I really mean this what I said
before if you're watching these videos
and you're part of this know that you
really are part of this and that's why
I'm so excited about what the question
was before people are having neat ups
you know when we walked out of the shows
so usually what happens at the end of
the show is if you pay a higher amount
of money Jordan doesn't meet-and-greet
with people and he and he stays and
takes pictures so I usually hang around
for a little bit I'll go out and lobby
and people say hi and I take a lot of
selfies and all that but sometimes and I
walk out of the theater sometimes I just
walk out the back and just because you
know it's been a long night and I've
said my hellos and whatever but every
now and again I'll walk out the front
and there literally will be hundreds of
people outside just talking they're just
talking to each other because they're
looking around and going wow this isn't
a white supremacist rally this isn't a
you know insel to hang out or whatever
it's like these are just good people who
are here for ideas to talk about some
stuff so that's why it's so cool because
this thing it's spreading it's spreading
in the right way not because we tricked
you or confused you or or or trying to
get something from you he doesn't sell
anything we don't sell anything at these
shows he doesn't even sell the books I
don't think I think maybe one show they
sold some books they're not even selling
books at the shows you know you mean
like then it's it's good it's time
telling you it's good what's going on ok
let's see you rock and it's time for the
IDW to come up with solutions or
proposals at least the brainpower that
you gather is amazing I agree I think
the next step of this is starting to
move to some more solution stuff we can
talk about this stuff we can identify
problems we can we can complain about
our side we can talk about the messed up
political system all of those things but
at some point you move into a position
where you got to talk about you got to
talk about answers right and solutions
and I think we're shifting there there's
been some discussions about this with
the whole crew and I think I think we
will get there let's see this is my
request to get Joe Rogan on your show
I've seen you on his show and I love the
back-and-forth love your show from Andre
in Aberdeen Scotland thank you my friend
we're working on getting Rogen it's just
he's told me he'll do it you know I mean
he did Shapiro's show before me which is
really [ __ ] up but yes he said he'll
do it I put in a request I emailed him
about September I believe it's September
11th to do my second show back oh and I
want to talk about going off the grid
because I am going off the grid for
August but I'll get back to that a
little bit let's see from wow you guys
wrote a lot of a lot of long-winded
stuff here let's see this is interesting
members of the IDW seem divided between
having a spirit of optimism or pessimism
regarding the future since it may be
tough to narrow it down to one what are
the three indicators that would help
sway someone towards an optimistic
outlook of the future of American
politics and culture when ivw members
say they are pessimistic about the
future what does that mean and what is
it what is the educated forecast about
what lies in the future and any chance
of you and pewters in doing some shows
in Australia
we've talked about that so we are
extending the tour the tour was
originally supposed to be just two
months May and June and then they extend
it into July I'm doing about six shows
with Jordan next week in all in Canada
then Jordans continuing for a few dates
in August I'm going off the grid in
August which as I said I'll tell you a
little bit more about momentarily but
then we did extend it into September and
October and and don't worry you're gonna
get shows from the Reuben report the
whole time even sometimes I'm coming
home and taping three shows and they're
leaving on a plane that night but we're
gonna keep pumping out content here and
being as attentive to everything we're
doing here is before I just think being
part of something that is so powerful
and culturally important and relevant is
is something that I want to continue
being part of so to your question about
this divide between the optimists and
the pessimist
so without without naming names
specifically so I would say and I've
said this before I would say I'm a
world-weary optimist I'm an optimist in
that I truly believe that most people
are basically good I think you want to
do good I think people want to be good
to the people around them I think they
want to be good in their community I
think people want to take care of
themselves and their property and not
kill and murder and maim and steal and
cheat now have we all done some of those
things do we all get off the path and we
all get confused and angry and act out
ways that are not good yes absolutely
but I truly believe that the the human
spirit whatever you want to call that
does want to be good I think you want to
do something you person watching this
right now you want to do something
fulfilling in your life that you feel
good about that doesn't feel meaningless
to you that you feel has some work for
you and hopefully your friends and your
family and your boyfriend or girlfriend
or whatever it is so to that end I'm an
optimist because I believe in that I
believe that is within all of us right
now I would say the world-weary part of
that is cuz it gets it gets kind of
[ __ ] up along the way right there's a
lot of bad actors out there you could
have you could have 80% good people
basically people trying to do good but
you've got 20% of loud influential bad
actors they can affect a lot of good
people and confuse a lot of people and I
think that that's what's partly happened
the media and this game of identity
politics has tried to turn us against
each other in the worst ways it really
has I mean think about it
just if you really wanted to i dissect
identity politics at the worst level
where we where some people should have
something based on the color of their
skin and get a job for this and if you
say okay look if you say someone based
on the color of their skin should have
more access to this education or this
job or whatever it is or their sexuality
or whatever their oppression might be or
perceived oppression it's not that all
sounds good right I want to help
somebody who's been marginalized okay
that sounds good on its head I want to
help somebody else but what you're also
saying is I'm going to help this person
that means you have to take something
away from somebody else who often
doesn't deserve to have something taken
away from I think this is why for last
year so I've been saying the next move
by the left was to come after the Asians
because Asians by and large Chinese
Japanese Korean whatever it is have put
an incredible focus on education and
work and family and because of that I
have moved up and up and up and I think
I think are pretty much at the highest
echelon of socioeconomic status and all
the ways that we judge it now what's
gonna happen and we know this is
happening we know this is happening at
Harvard and Google had this thing where
they work on a higher male Asian
engineers is you're gonna start
punishing those people most Asian people
their grandparents or whatever was came
here with nothing just like my grandpa
great grandparents came there was
nothing most like most likely your
great-grandparents whatever it is came
here with nothing should we now start
punishing people who did the right thing
along the way of course not but now what
do you do if there are some groups that
have been harmed more than others by
certain things well I would say maybe
you can invest more in education right
maybe we can look at what are we doing
with with prison laws and things like
that in prison reform but the idea this
identity politics why it is so dangerous
is that it will start pitting us against
each other for all of the wrong reasons
you can be against somebody because of
their ideas and not and you know that
okay so that person's probably at this
person's pro-choice well so you're not
killing each other you can be against
each other
but if we keep if we start putting laws
in place that are gonna codify the the
dangers of identity politics you're
gonna actually have Asian people angry
at black people you're gonna have white
people angry at this person you're this
person angry this person not because of
their ideas and their their truths and
who they are but because of their
immutable characteristics you will put
prejudice into laws that's where this
all hit so that's what we have to fight
and I'm an optimist because of all the
reasons that I've said for the last 45
minutes I think something cool is
happening oh but I was gonna say this
earlier you know when I've said we're
winning
Jordan's brought up an interesting point
at some of the stories because I'll say
to the crowd you know something like I
feel like we're winning it's so cool and
everybody starts applauding and going
crazy and they look around and they see
other people and yeah it's awesome
but what Jordan's point has been is that
it's not you it's not that you wanna win
because if you win that means the person
who you're with is the loser and we
don't want half the country to feel like
losers because they will get really
angry and upset and everything else so
what you want to do is you want to wake
up as many people as possible to good
ideas I think that that's where the
focus has to be as for those that are
those are the crew that maybe you're
pessimists there's are a lot of reasons
to be pessimists and maybe that is just
something fundamentally built in to who
we are but for now and you know only 42
I still got a little optimism in me okay
super chat I'm an atheist conservative
and just you as a person make me feel
super accepted well that's awesome
that's great to hear yes there are
atheists conservatives it's incredible
there's all sorts of people out there
and it's not just what the media tells
you let's see I've been bugging Heather
on Twitter to make Brett make more
content they're both great and their
ideas always make me question mind
they're both spectacular you have not
seen my interview with Heather I which
we posted I think two weeks ago it's
phenomenal what a what a tour de force
and intellectual heft she is I just
loved every moment of it we'll
definitely do more with her I should
tell you by the way that you know as
these tours are going on and Sam's doing
the stuff with
Peterson and Peterson I are continuing
this thing we are working on all sorts
of things in the future
that I can't quite get into now that
will have a technological component that
could happen a touring component and all
sorts of stuff so so stay tuned I think
there's so many cool things happening
and you guys are all part of it my
friends okay let's see I'll jump back
into patreon for a moment Dave keep up a
good work on the diet and exercise plan
you look 10 years younger than you did
six months ago you know I feel like I
look younger and I definitely feel
better you know I mentioned something
that I mentioned on the Rogan podcast so
about three about three years ago right
when the Rubin report was first taking
off so this is when we were on aura TV
this is the bleep this started it was
around February or March of 2016 so we
relaunched the show in September of 2015
at or at emia Larry King's digital
network and that was my first real
interview was the first time I met
Samaras and had him on I think that was
September 9th 2015 then the show really
started blowing up I had I had maajid on
and I had this Mari and I under C Ali
and a whole bunch of people I started
really talking about what I thought was
wrong with the last I started really
focusing on free speech the show was
growing and growing and growing and
growing I started getting a lot of hate
at the same time and I had never really
gotten hate before and I guess I was
more stressed than I thought I was
because around February or March I
started losing just chunks and chunks of
hair mostly from the back of my head but
I lost a lot up here I mean I'm talking
like I would take a shower just like it
was awful like handfuls a hair falling
out I went to to a dermatologist I want
to do a specialist it turns out I
developed something called alopecia
areata which is an autoimmune disease
they don't know exactly what causes it I
didn't have any blood problems or
anything like that
but basically your white blood cells
start attacking your hair follicles and
they don't know why so I ended up going
on this I told this story to Rogan
couple weeks ago I ended up going on a
pretty experimental drug which I can't
even remember what
it's called right now it's got a crazy
long name that basically was like
putting like this cream that was like it
was like putting poison ivy on my head
and I had to put it on at night David
who put it on my head and in effect what
that would do is it would cause an
allergic reaction so that the white
blood cells would attack the reaction
instead of hair follicles well anyway
this is a pretty experimental thing and
as I did it I had to do it for a couple
months I I was breaking out like you
wouldn't believe like my entire body was
itchy like almost everything except my
face which was a freaking miracle was
itchy and red and kind of flaky I
couldn't really be out in the Sun I'm
talking about for almost a year and it
was it was miserable I mean my my head
like I was having a imagine putting
imagine rubbing poison ivy on your head
like itching and oozing I mean it's
really gross to even talk about it was
it was pretty miserable and and I didn't
tell anybody about it I mean David knew
and my mom folks knew maybe my brother
and sister like a couple people but I
didn't I didn't want you guys know but
anyway this medication it also caused I
was kind of like inflamed a little bit
and I definitely was like a little more
bloated and I I definitely I did not
look great I wasn't sleeping up that
well and if anything it added more if I
was trying to get rid of stress it added
more stress and it really sucked because
it was happening at the same exact point
as I was becoming really successful
which is some sort of an interesting
thing that life deals you with things
and it's interesting because I've talked
about this privately with your and I
hope he doesn't mind me if I quickly
mentioned this year but you know in the
last two years as Jordan has succeeded
he started having some some real
digestive issues you know he's doing
he's doing a very strict carnivore diet
right now which you know he doesn't
really like talking about because he's
not a dietician he's not telling anyone
to do what he's doing but we both dealt
with sort of helped issues as as we were
succeeding which is a really weird thing
like as all the things that you care
about that are good are working that you
suddenly have something that's
completely out of your control happening
to you so anyway it really really sucked
and yeah I definitely did not look great
and it's not fun having like
thing that you don't want to talk about
with people and all that stuff it's it's
mostly gone but actually today I just
went to the to the dermatologist I still
do this is all my hair all my hair right
here but I still do have a couple spots
in the back which is why my hair is a
little bit longer in the back and once a
month I get cortisone shots which I
think we're gonna actually stop doing I
discussed with my dermatologist today
because it's hard to tell if it's
actually working but some are growing
back and sometimes randomly they'll be
like a little spot that just appears
they describe it as like an amber and a
fire just magically appears but anyway
it's just it's just one of those things
and you never know what somebody's
actually dealing with and I guess just
trying to be decent to people I have VIP
tickets for a show in Cincinnati how can
i interact with you and JP without
making a fool of myself I have to know
more about you specifically no but
Cincinnati I'll make sure that I come
out in the audience for a little bit and
then try to grab me and say hi I thought
this AI let's see when the right is the
only side that is tolerant for differing
opinions lifestyles and perspectives how
do I avoid embracing them not out of
alignment with all of their principles
but out of disgust and rejection from
the new extreme left I love this
question I'm a classical liberal but
it's hard when I feel like I'm so alone
in the mainstream narrative when talking
to people who don't follow things like
the IDW or a Peterson or who are so
brainwashed by progressivism okay I know
a lot about this cuz I'm kinda in the
boat with you right like the people that
five years ago I thought were the bad
guys the evil conservatives and Shapero
and play tour and these scary people
once you get to know them you realize
they're not that bad and just because
somebody believes in limited government
and low taxes doesn't mean they hate
poor people and just because somebody is
is pro-life which I am NOT doesn't mean
that they hate women or all the memes
that unfortunately the left has put out
there to make it seem like anyone who
doesn't believe in their orthodoxy is an
evil person or a Nazi or a white
supremacist or anything and I know that
literally millions of you are waking up
to this I have absolutely no doubt about
it so how do you deal with it well look
I can tell you this I I know I'm friends
with all sorts of conservatives and
people on the right
go to these turning-point USA things
I'll be in DC next week I'm doing the
turning-point USA High School summit
it's the largest gathering of high
school conservatives I think in the
country I'll be speaking I think Trump
jr. is gonna be there and Sam Gork is
gonna be there Candace Owens will be
there in bah-bah-bah I have big
political differences with these people
and I go to these turning-point things
and charlie Kirk said to me I said it to
him when he sat in this thing right here
he said to me privately the first day I
met him within two minutes he said Dave
I have a lot of big disagreements with
you but I'd love for you to start coming
to some turning-point events and I can
tell you this I go to these events I
talk about being gay married approached
oice and against the death penalty and
for reforming prison systems and being
against the war on drugs and a whole
slew of other things that these guys
aren't really for and I find them to be
incredibly engaging and open and nice
and decent and fun so yes are there some
things that I don't like about them sure
are they a little too conservative for
my style yes but is there room to build
some alliances over there they're damn
well is and I'm gonna keep doing it and
it sounds like you're gonna keep doing
it too and I think the more that you do
that and the more that we show people
that we can we can be friends with
people we disagree with and we can show
people that we don't have to be
endlessly hysterical or outraged you're
angry they're gonna run out of steam and
I think we're starting to see some of
that right now they really are going to
run out of steam and let's just build a
home where enough people can come into
it uh find some answers um super chat do
you get concerned about overexposure
with folks like you Shapiro Peterson and
others all over YouTube and click
clickbait videos out there causing
discord are you concerned and if yes do
you have any strategies for addressing
it so I think there is some element of
that right like a lot of us are out
there doing a lot of different things
we're doing each other's shows we're
doing many other people's shows we're
doing live events we're doing podcasts
all that I'm somewhat aware of it and
I've actually in the last two months or
so and it partly is because of the tour
and I just out of time I've turned out a
lot of media requests I will be on
Tucker Carlson tomorrow night actually
and people always only go on Tucker ear
and grünfeld you only go on Fox News CNN
and MSNBC have never invited me I can't
just stand out there and go
but you let me in so I'll go where I'm
go where I can go and be on live and
unedited Gregg's show is live to tape so
they air it the next day but I know
Gregg well and he's friend and they've
never edited a word and he's promised me
that they never would and Tucker is
there a lot so I have no problem doing
that
I much prefer to do it in studio and
when I'm in DC then I been doing the
camera thing cuz it's a little weird you
sit in a little room and you stare at a
little box and that's it can't see him
you're just looking at that thing and
talk with that so it's a little weird
but that's what I'll be doing tomorrow
because I'm here in LA see but as far as
overexposure I would say we all have to
be somewhat aware of it but you know
it's a little bit you know it's kind of
like like I don't see the term
progressive left anymore like really
when's the last time you heard me say I
very very rarely say it and if I do it I
usually say it in a joking matter for
all that year that I had to say it all
the time was because we were trying to
identify a problem and sometimes you
need a word to identify it and the idea
that they were not progressive for real
progress which would be for equality but
they were aggressive they wanted us to
look backwards they wanted us to not do
the things that Martin Luther King jr.
wanted us to do it was a word that
really stuck which by the way just the
record one more time Maajid Nawaz came
up with the word I just was one of the
people that helped amplify it okay now I
don't use it anymore because I think
sometimes once you've identified
something enough you don't have to keep
going back to it other people can use it
whatever you can figure out other ways
to talk about things I think there there
is some risk because there's a bunch of
us now and we're all kind of picking up
steam in different ways there's some
risk of some level of overexposure I
don't think we've hit it yet what I
would say is if you're asking me this
question and I guess for those of you
that are watching this right now most of
you obviously new people are coming on
board all the time but a lot of you the
core group of you that watch all of
these videos and they care about this
stuff and then come up to us on the
streets and all that you've been around
for a while so some of this may seem
occasionally repetitive to you or oh
I've heard that before whatever but
really what you have to think about them
I'm keenly aware of this because
sometimes I will have to repeat myself
when I say something or if I give a
speech I usually try to have no notes in
front of me but every now and again
there's a couple lines that I know I've
said before that I really want to hit on
you got to remember that there's so many
new
coming to these ideas and these ideas
still are ignored by mainstream and the
more they ignore them the more people
tune them out and they tune us in so
because of the amount of new people that
are coming in we do have to be somewhat
aware of not becoming caricatures of
ourselves by overly repeating things I
have discussed this privately with
Peterson a little bit I think we all
have to be aware of it and you guys
those of you that are that are good
decent people I mean if you see it if it
seems like you know we were just oh
about he's going to his old hits instead
of thinking of new stuff and figuring
out what's next please call us out and
by the way that's why the question
earlier was so good about well alright
well how do we start talking about
solutions because I don't always want to
just talk about the ideas I also want to
figure out what's next which also is why
when I had been and Jordan and arigon
here too two or three weeks ago I said
do you guys think this is the beginnings
of a political movement and they all had
sort of different answers not that but
look if it starts becoming a political
movement are some of us suddenly
political consultants or political
candidates or spokespeople who the hell
notes but let's let's keep going let's
keep going and see what happens all
right and there's a lot of good stuff
here so a couple of you have asked me
about can you look into Comics gate and
interview Ethan Van Sciver what's going
on in the comic-book community is crazy
so I've gotten a couple emails about
this I've heard about this a little bit
let me do a little bit more research
I'll see what I can do I see there's a
bunch of super check questions about
that oh oh he's the illustrator from
from 12 rules for life right okay give
me a little time on this one to pull
this one all together okay let me jump
back into patreon a couple people asking
about Obama and the comments I addressed
that earlier yes I do think he could
possibly bring some sanity left but I
don't know hey Dave personal question
are you a novel reader if so what are
some of your favorite novels so I
haven't really been reading novels
lately because I've been reading more
books of the people that come in here I
am reading a CS Elliott short story
right now or it's not a short story it's
it but it's a thin book oh man I can't
remember what it's called
I've read about half of it already it's
in my tribe
if someone wants to see if they can find
it but I'm really enjoying that it's
about these these two guys that
basically kidnap another guy and bring
him to to another planet Oh somebody
help me with this what the hell is a
call okay um you should get this person
a lot of Dave you need to get Joel
kotkin on the show I've seen a couple
about him I think his criticism about
text embraces progressiveness
progressive causes are right in line
with the intellectual dark web I'll look
into that I'll look into that but look
even that even the tech companies are
starting to get it I'm hearing I can't I
can't tell you every conversation I have
but I'm hearing from big tech CEOs these
days I mean not everyone not everyone is
a progressive and a lot of them feel
hostages of their own companies because
of the way this craziness has spread and
I think they are starting to wake up I
don't think it's a coincidence in fact I
know it's not a coincidence that Peter
Thiel is moving down to LA and getting
out of Silicon Valley what progressivism
does in its current incarnation is it
stifles thought it stifles thought and
it demands obedience and you I know if
you are like me you don't want to bow
and you and you certainly don't want to
bow forever and that's what they demand
out at you and it's and it's sucky and
it's shitty and don't do it okay let's
see I heard you on Joe Rogan talking
about next-gen after Millennials he said
that the next generation will be
different because of the [ __ ] they see
now do you agree so there's a couple
interesting things happen here right so
I'm I'm Generation X right so I'm after
the baby boomers then there was
Generation X then there's Generation Y
so I'm 42
Generation Y is people I think that are
basically sort of in their late 20s to
mid 30s I think I think 35 is the cut
offs of Generation X but you know these
things are little amorphous and then
there was the millennial generation and
the Millennial Generation is sort of the
generation that ushered in the the
outrage and you know obsession with
technology analyst um I don't blame them
for any of it because they were brought
up on all this stuff and you know
feelings over facts and the rest of it
then there's been a bunch of studies
that the generation beneath them the
generation that's like in junior
and I think I think probably it's a high
school now but they're actually growing
up much more conservative that they
realize that these endless screaming and
and hating each other and identity
politics that they're against all of
these things and there's been a comeback
to some sort of conservative values
however you want to define that I think
that's really interesting
and I think we're gonna keep seeing the
the fruits of that but more than
anything else I mean I think a through
line of this conversation that we're
having today is that let's give people a
better option for the future like right
even right now let's say you're a huge
maggot person you're a huge Trump person
right now well I think everyone realizes
whatever side you're on right now
I think everyone realizes this this
level of tension and us against them
whatever side you're on it can't last
forever what could happen is it could
snap and something really awful could
happen right but I think what actually
could happen is out of the chaos that
seemingly is happening now is that
eventually the chaos won't be needed any
the the disruption that Trump was to the
system eventually won't be needed and
then perhaps some principled
conservatives some principled
libertarians some principled liberals
and perhaps even I'll put it out there
some some principled progressives who I
may disagree with but are principled can
actually start coming out of the
woodwork again let's talk about it
several times here I think it's starting
to happen I think there's some signs of
it's pretty cool all right here's what
we're gonna go for about ten more
minutes so if you got any any other
super chats or questions on on patreon
let me know what else did I want to just
tell you real quick oh let's see so one
other thing that I wanted to hit on
before before I wrap up and then I'll
hit a couple other questions is so I am
going off the grid in August so I did
this last year I literally locked my
phone on a safe from August first until
the last day of August and then my first
show back last year which was with was
with Phil DeFranco my intention actually
for my first show back in September
right after Labor Day was to not know
anything I was just gonna come back
with Phil and Phil obviously talks about
the news often and I think he's I think
he's a great guy and I think he's doing
great stuff my intention was to not know
anything the night before I came back at
the last minute I was invited to a
pretty power player dinner where all
sorts of current events I knew were
going to be discussed so I met Eric
Weinstein first for a glass of wine and
he just unloaded on me on what had
happened over the course of the month
and it was all this North Korea stuff
and the Charlottesville thing and it's
Dillian or things that I had no idea
about he just like downloaded them all
into my brain and then we go off to
decide big influential dinner it was it
was pretty nutty but this this year I am
I'm gonna go off the entire time at the
end of July these last couple of days
were taping a ton of stuff so you will
have shows every week we are not taking
a week off by the way we have josephine
mathias on tomorrow who many of you guys
know from youtube my name is Josephine
she's just just absolutely wonderful and
I've got to know her in person a little
bit saw her in Toronto and she's just
lovely and a really smart cool fun
thinker but anyway we'll put up shows in
August and I'm gonna challenge some of
you I don't know exactly how we're gonna
do this so when I do the off-the-grid
thing I literally phone in a safe I'm
not gonna watch TV I'm not gonna do
anything electronic I'm gonna work on my
book again I'm gonna ask you were going
away for a little bit of escape and try
to relax and just enjoy myself and
whatever else and seize family and
friends I know that a lot of people
can't can't do that like that level of
off the grimness or disappear but I am
gonna figure out a way maybe we'll do a
video about it the day before I go to
challenge some of you guys you know I've
been trying to do it on the weekends I
don't try I really really try not to
look at my phone or at least use social
media on the weekends I think people do
need an escape I think if there's ever a
month to do it I think August is the
month to do it I would love to challenge
some of you to really do it with me if
you could really what if you really
didn't even just social media I know it
would be hard for some of you that
because of work you wouldn't not be able
to email let's say but even if you just
got off social media for a month like
what would it be like and I can tell you
that there's a level of withdrawal like
the first couple days my hand kept going
into my pocket where's my phone and then
by day four or five it starts kind of
feeling good and then that by day eight
it's kind of empowering your
holy cow I don't need any of that and
then you you your attention span returns
and you start interacting with strangers
more one of the things I noticed I don't
necessarily the sounds like such a
little nonsensical thing but I really
noticed this I was at the supermarket
after about 20 days of being off the
grid and I remember you know putting my
stuff on the belt and the girl the
cashier is there and I just started
being friendlier - how you doing what's
going on oh I saw you here last week oh
this thing that I thought like this was
this was pretty good so I bought it
again whatever and it was like you can
make room in your brain again to be the
way we were 20 years ago like of course
technology's great you're watching this
on YouTube right now we can connect in
all these different ways right I meet
some of you guys in real life because of
this
but just remember 20 years ago we had
none of this stuff and we had none of
this stuff for the thousands of years of
humanity before that so I'm looking
forward to the escape I will challenge
some of you to join me for the month and
just see what happens but even if you
can only get off get off so to speak for
the weekend or whatever it is I think it
would be pretty cool so hopefully some
of you guys will join me for that oh and
then I will tell you this our first show
back is on September 4th it's the day
after Labor Day I am not gonna know
anything and I will be a guest on the
Rubin report we have a guest host on the
Rubin report who is going to give you
he's gonna interviewer I just said it's
a he ok it's a he he's gonna interview
me and fill me in on all the things that
I missed and you guys will we'll watch
that live as I get the full download
live we're gonna do that on September
4th but I'm not saying who it is um you
know what I think may be a moment ago
that I said that Josephine is a
conservative I don't know that actually
she's I don't think she fully I think
she's a classical liberal I think she's
got some conservative views and the
reason I said that was because she did a
video that I think was titled black
people can be conservative I don't think
she herself identifies as a conservative
so Josephine if you're watching I
apologize for miss labeling you there's
nothing worse oh the book that I love
silent planet CS Lewis so it's a trilogy
I mean I'm still on the first one but
I'm gonna knock it out
hopefully on my next travel and all
right let's see
super chat the interesting thing about
watching so many of you for so long is
that it helps cement the ideas but we
also get to see the evolution of the
ideas and arguments love your work
especially with Jordan thank you very
much there's a bunch of you that wrote a
lot of nice things about me thank you I
love what you do man took me from
ignoring all the noise to finding some
hope for honest discussion and port
conversations thank you
IDW I have themed specific shows for
example having bread and Dawkins on
would be great at multiples perspective
from specialist yeah so we're thinking
about all of this stuff and I think
partly once we figure out how we can
tour more you know it's not easy to put
these things together and manage we got
people that live in all sorts of parts
of the parts of the country and you know
Douglas Murray for example and Maajid
both live in the UK so we're figuring it
all out we got a lot of cool stuff
planned I'm super psyched about
everything that's going on oh and by the
way the show is expanding we are we are
building out our team just yesterday
actually we hired a new team member who
I will introduce to you at some point
along the road but yeah you guys that
support us whether it's on patreon or
PayPal super check you're helping us
build out this thing and and I hope
you're proud of it I hope you're excited
and as excited at least as I am and all
right so I think we're gonna wrap this
thing for now I just wanted to catch up
on a whole bunch of stuff or yeah I
think we'll probably do a live stream it
possible on July 31st so that it can be
my official goodbye and my official
challenge for you guys to join me off
the grid if you can and then as I said
we got we got new content coming out all
of August we got some really cool stuff
planned for for September there was a
huge guest that I thought we were gonna
have in May yeah that it got delayed up
a little bit I think that's happening in
September and just keep fighting the
fight guys like just keep keep fighting
keep giving people a chance to to to
learn with you to not judge them as
quickly as they would judge you and
let's see what we can keep building here
because it's happening it's happening
whether we like it or not I happen to
like it but it's happening whether we
like it or not so thank you guys oh and
by the way if you want to get your
classical liberal
a t-shirt I believe the link is right
down below you can go to rubin report
comm slash store there's some other
rubin report stuff on there and all that
good stuff all right I am going to
dinner thanks guys
see ya oh and we'll get the freakin
TriCaster working next time so you don't
have to stare at me looking at my
computer okay